flush em enables non-programmers to
perform sophisticated data manipulation
tasks by leveraging various programming
by example and natural language
technologies consider the following text
file each record consists of a person's
name an address suppose we want to
convert the names from first name space
last name format into last name comma
first initial format and also count how
many people live in Redmond the first
step is to extract the fields want to
work with using the flash extract tool
and giving examples
next we give examples of where the
cities are
now it can add the data simply by using
the flash fill tool and giving examples
click on the run to get a preview and
click confirm now we can count the
number of people live in Redmond by
simply issuing a command in natural
language using the analyze tool like so
and there's the answer 7